hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast graduate from shaker to
fermenter I am Judy Oracle a birds and
I'll be your moderator for today's event
we are delighted to bring this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by eppendorf
eppendorf is a leading life science
company that develops and sells
instruments consumables and services for
liquid sample and cell handling
performed in laboratories around the
globe for more information please visit
eppendorf com we have a few important
announcements before we begin this
webcast is designed to be interactive
and we encourage you to ask questions
during the event you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window we'll try to
answer as many questions as we can you
can enlarge the slide window by clicking
on the screen icon in the lower right
hand corner of the slide window if you
have any technical problems viewing or
hearing this presentation please click
on the support button at the top right
of your presentation window or submit
your problem through the green Q&A
button at lower left I would now like to
introduce today's speaker mutual aid or
Sue's bioprocess application specialist
at eppendorf North America mutual aid or
say true says a bachelor's degree in
biology and chemistry from salem state
university he has been working in
process development and manufacturing in
the biotechnology and biopharmaceutical
industry for over 12 years he has worked
for Abbott Wyeth Massachusetts biologic
laboratory Shire pharmaceutical and now
with epidural fourth America I will now
turn it over to our speaker for his
presentation
thank you Judy good morning everybody
and thank you for participating in
today's webinar my name is mr. doses and
i'll be your speaker for today and
today's webinar we're going to discuss
graduate from sugar to fermenter Asajj
bioreactor today's webinar will focus
primarily on several part first we're
going to touch a traditional method of
cell culture second we're going to
discuss briefly the benefit of
bioreactors our stash fermenter and
looking at a small scale and single-use
buyer at the solution just available and
and also looking at some future of
bioreactor such as bag at the design and
we can look at at the mood of operations
and bioreactors and various technology
for suspension and also encourage self
cell-dependent self dependent system
technology available out there now and
in this webinar it will be mostly
beneficial to the scientist and engineer
who currently right now culturing o
fermenting using a Spanish class and
also check flaps and an incubator so
without further ado we cannot have to
start traditional traditional scallop
method for suspension cell in a HeLa
cell culture is showing in this slide
here as you can see on to the left you
have a frozen by which one can obtain
from a working cell bank or master cell
thing then they will take that vial and
follow it out into a single class and as
the cell density increase or grow and
they would then aliquoted and further
spring split the cells into a multiple
flash and basically after this the cell
density increase from that
from the sequence then they would
basically transfer it into the
technology platform they are using so as
you can see on the right if they are
using the phone attachment cells they
can transfer it to the logic class a
large dish water bottle of sales sell
stock chambers hyper-strike vessels or
eq system or if they are using a
suspension adopted cells and they can
use a spin class or ash a class for
today's webinar will mostly discuss the
suspension method for adapt itself self
object traditionally this slide is
showing the growth mechanism that been
used and going the cells we discussed in
the previous slide so to the top left
you see you t flask you choose for the
adherent cell line along on the top
right you see the pictures of your
multi-well plate which also use for the
attachment cell line and on the middle
you have your spinner flash and your
ship flash on the bottom left of the
slide now for our discussion has
mentioned we're going to be focused
primarily on those two platform
technologies now spin of flats just i
showing spinner flats which have a range
from 125 mill up to 36 liters still up
to 36 litre as you can see they can
accommodate anywhere from from one times
ten to the eighth sales total all the
way up to three times ten to the tenth
cells with a working volume range
anywhere from 100 to 36 litre now as as
you can see they are some limiting
factor on that because as you find your
target molecule you are trying to
produce the maximum you can actually
produce is 36
leader so they're that right actually a
botanist will be exploring further and
to add to our presentation next one is
what we're looking at is some advantage
and disadvantage if you look on the
advantage checks and you look at days
they are very economical and come back
to use the Spanish they are simple to
harvest you pretty much just remove this
manner we undo vsc and you brought the
content of you cell culturing Oh
microbial fermentation that you or
growing it is less limber intensive been
flattened and world apart some of the
disadvantage is it's difficult to feed
the culture because you can't fit it in
an open air due to contamination so you
have to remove it from the from the
incubator and bring it into biological
safety cabinet and I'll try to basically
maneuver it around lean it over and try
to feel it that way so that make it a
bit challenging at time to feed and also
it required a magnetic stirrer so which
means that you need to start to be
inside the incubator so you need in a
store that is can stay a long time and
they CO 2 incubator without going bad
and also it's quietly incubator as the
mechanism to provide temperature control
gasps delivering also pH control as well
and it's also require a lot of labor to
decontaminate clean and reassemble and
sterile as well so next we have a
typical shake flask so this [ __ ] class
is it is more common in today instead
expansion and also media study so the
shake flask on both in class and also in
single use you have chi classes that
have that come with buffer for better
mixing you
have also they come either vented with a
vented cap and non vented as well for
different various application as you can
see on the slide they range from 50 ml
to six liter and can accommodate cell
density ranging anywhere from two times
ten to the seven cells all the way up to
two times ten to the ninth so and also
with a working volume from 15 mil all
the way 2.4 again as you can see we have
a working volume limitation here so if
you wanted to go beyond that
unfortunately you would have to really
have more shake flask which then would
occupy you would need more incubators
and more personnel tool to you to run it
and also you would need more space as
well next we're going to touch base on
some of the advantage disadvantage of
[ __ ] class as well it they are very
economical in compact as well it's
simple to harvest and they some include
baffle for gas exchange and it's easy to
scale up from your 50 miles all the way
up to 63 because they dramatically a
very similar so this disadvantage they
only use for suspension cell culture
unless you use like technology such as
micro carrier inside I want to go
attachment cell they only use for
suspension cell and as same as the spin
bottle they also require incubators and
also they shake flasks acquire a shaking
up artist that would allow it to mix and
transfer oxygen and also gets to control
the pH as well next what we're looking
at is a unibody you mattify co2
incubator and shaker you mattify co2
incubator is used to further both the
spinner flats and also the shaker as
well if you modify because it's help
with
volume loss in the culture without as we
know if we can and in cell culture if
you don't you modified you would have
some volume notes in your shake flat and
your culture which would in return and
Krista concentration of your media and
that may not be good for the cells
health overall as you can see here on
the slide on the top left there are
three parameters on some of these
shakers you have temperature and you
have your co2 and air conditioned and
also some have the agitation as well
sweet recorded now in the middle of that
you you'll have an incubate CO 2
incubator that come embedded with a
whipped HD shaker on it that way you
don't have a second mechanism that can
go bad in the shaker because the
incubator already come with this shape
like soda with the shaking platforms all
you really do really is insert your
shake flask now for the spinners are
ever you need to have a stirrer so and
some in the middle incubator you would
have to remove that shaking platform and
insert a stirrer so that way you can run
your process that is in the spinner
flash now in in terms of scale up will
to generate larger volume as you can see
in the middle as well you pretty much
which is used a lot more shake flask and
old spinner to spend because you have a
size limitation so you can't go past six
liter for the shakers and 36 litre for
the spanish as well now next we're going
to take a look at some process parameter
for the sugar and spinner flats so
temperature as we discussed is primarily
controlled by incubator the incubator
typically maintained anywhere fun from
37 for yourself or for yourself girl and
also anywhere from 30
one as well gas transfer is
predominantly done to the vented cap and
that is also done inside the incubator
usually there is a mixing of a of air
and co 2 whereas is used as the oxygen
supply and the co2 to control the pH pH
is not controlled or martyred it's so
therefore a lot of the time you have to
buffer your media very well in order to
maintain the pH at a desired set point
and you put the pH pretty much will do a
drift over time agitation is done in the
[ __ ] class by the shaking platform and
you the scientist or engineer decided
what is you decide rpm going to be feed
is done manually primarily and under
biological safety cabinet to prevent
contamination and the deal is not
control or monitored and co2 as well as
like controller monitored and scallop as
I say it can be a challenge due to size
limitation so because of all these
bottleneck and limitation what we have
to address some of this concern is the
rise of a bioreactor so next slide we
are going to cover some of the benefit
of a bioreactor and if / fermenters will
we address some of the bottlenecks and
issues we have with shaking platform as
well as this spanner is right now
without the benefit of a bioreactor and
as you can see on the right here is a
sample of a small-scale bioreactor and
which come is a stirred tank reactor
which able to accommodate a suspension
cell as well at a hit here independent
cell
it's autumn knife automatically
controlled for your pH you do 02 and
also temperature as well unlike your
standard shake flat and I mean a CO 2
incubator or and also this manner as
well where you don't have any control at
all you pretty much rely on the buffer
and your media to help maintain you pH
control and for your temperature you
rely primarily on the nqr incubator to
supply with the right temperature well
with the but the bioreactor that's get
taken care for you automatically because
it is a more specialized equipment that
is designed to help you maintain and
control and monitoring you process
parameters set point next you have the
process flexibility one great thing
about bioreactor does is provide you
with the option to basically run all
type of processes such as your batch
fed-batch and also as well as perfusion
we will explore these processes later on
in our discussion next you have scalable
problem so the barrier to make it very
easy to scale up which help address the
bottle next we have with shake flash and
Spanish with the limitation from 36
liters for the spinners and also to six
liters in the chi class so with entire
reactor really you can scale up to large
anywhere from from 50 mils all the way
up to five hundred thousand liters in a
certain bioreactor it's very robust and
it's the agitation is also used in
fermentation as a source of help
delivering oxygen as well to help
maintain oxygen setpoint and you also
have aeration which is done to ascend it
seals fajr or can also down to a macro
sparge to basically help me
can you desire do set point next weekend
looking apps on some small scale and
single-use bioreactor that's currently
available in the end the industry which
primarily use for media optimizations
clone clone and cell line screening
strain characterization of brian process
development as well now you have the
small-scale bioreactor is Ben is
currently been using right now in
biopharmaceutical biochemical field and
nutrition as well using across all the
processes such as research and
development your process development and
also type in manufacturing as well now
what is started to gain ground in our
industry is that instead of using
various [ __ ] plants to scale up a lot of
scientists now is using small scale
bioreactors to basically doing cell line
optimization their media screening so
that way they can go directly from the
small-scale bioreactor into the
large-scale production bioreactor once
they have discovered the ideal molecule
so that tend to be an ongoing platform
in the throughout the industry
next you have is here is really looking
at the mini bioreactor system showing
the option that it comes in instead of
full set of 8 12 ohmahgah so you can
have and one one great thing about it is
that give you the flexibility with the
working volume range from anywhere from
60 to 250 mm what's great about that is
we all know media is very costly so it's
defined to find a barrier that you
cannot add 60 ml is very it's not only
cost saving but also that each mimic you
process at the large scale so it so once
you basically establish a process in
this small starting bioreactor as long
as you buy actor is true geometrically
similar then you should be able to just
scale up to you large pilot or process
development or your production scale
vessel as well now what's great about
this system is that it comes with both
glass for your autoclavable that's
autoclavable and also single use
technology so the single use technology
really is great because that's allow you
to still have the same flexibility you
have with your shake / you pretty much
to experiment and then at the end of you
run you can we have the option to just
toss does that I've got a single use oh
I also give you the flexibility if you
want to use glass pan so at the end of
you alter you just pretty much I'm
washing the other way when we use you
lastly a bioreactor now as discussed
this system really because of its
contacts and flexibility and also is a
small range of volume each make it ideal
for design of experiment and scale down
over so we have a lot of customers right
now using it really for design of
experiment in scale down approach next
we're looking at some of the industry's
standard process control capabilities of
the system as you can see abalone the
slide your head
you control parameters such as you Phu
deal and temperature and agitation as we
discuss and the system is able to
control that for you your set point
automatically for you without really
have to worry too much also you have
your liquid feed the system also control
your feet for you and including any
corrective agent that you may have such
as bass acid controls and also control
the gas delivery any levels or redox
flow of you may have ins also come with
an optional of gas analysis as well so
because of this kind of those all those
features an option and also flexibility
it really is the optimal design tools
for deal we examine expand next we have
here really if you can see in this slide
was showing her compact system is so you
have in a six foot of space we able to
fit in about 24 vessel as you can see
here you also have the option really 24
for those customers who in the lab are
working with due process such as
fermentation as well as cell culture you
can split the system if you can see the
first 12 on the left is a fermentation
culture and on the right is for cell
culture so this is a very compact and
which make it an idea for screening
characterization of the optimization as
well without occupying too much bench
space next what we have is the mini by
reactor itself showing how compact it is
it set so you have your glass body with
a stainless steel head plate it's easy
to handle and unscrew the caps on as we
discussed earlier come with a working
volume of 60 200 to 250 meals you have a
ratio of two to one with total volumes
350
it is come with an overhead drive using
the miniature lip seal assembly you have
the option for Rushton and fellow for
you fermentation culture can we get with
a marine or page blade for yourself
cultural heritage it's also come
integrated with the exhaust condenser as
well so the great thing about this
exhaust condenser it is liquid free so
you don't have to worry about liquid
accumulation which may drop bacteria and
may cause contamination it's also come
equipped with utilize of off the shelf
and pH and do sensor from all the sensor
you can pretty much use any sensor
provider with the system as well so it
is a true bioreactor that you can use to
develop your process next what we're
showing here is the single-use vessel we
have to the left is the microbial
single-user vessel and the middle is our
self ultra single-use vessel and all to
the right is a [ __ ] bad system which can
be used for the adherent or their touch
cell as well as suspension as well
that's what we have really is the single
use family scalability issues so if you
were to use the single use and you're
early benchtop Prosser development and
it's I'm gonna make it easier for you to
just really scale up to the pilots eyes
all the way up to 50 litre with a
working volume up to 40 as you can see
there is various range of agitations
arranged anywhere from 20 and the point
3c bioreactor all the way up to 150 rpm
for our 50 for single use 50 litre and
with various working
next what we have here is a temperature
and agitation controlled the system we
come with an independent as we discuss
is a liquid free heating and cooling
come with the heating and cooling for in
fermentation control and also the
heating for you cell culture processes
can control from temperature range
anywhere from 10 to 60 degrees Celsius
as far as agitation we of the system
come with a brushless overhead drive you
have agitation range from anywhere from
20 RPM all the way up to 25 at the end
as you can see here to the right right
next to bioreactor there is various type
of impellers so you have your ration
type impeller as well as you page played
along with the marine to accommodate
different processes such as cell culture
in fermentation as well next we have the
integrated gas mixing system which is
used physically to maintain you do set
point are you co2 stripping we have come
with continuous mixing of air nitrogen
oxygen and also co2 you have it fully
mass flow control you have a total of
sixteen mass flow controller powerful
powerful full unit you have gas range
flow from five standard liter per hour
into a max of 25 cent Lydia per hour and
you have the option to either have i
submerge sparger or an overlay gas can
also be configured to the system
next what we have is a feeding and
watering system as you can see here on
the top right that is a the pumps that
the system used to feed the culture that
you have grown with a issue of
experimentation Oh bio cell culture so
you have so so you have miniature
peristaltic pump using variable speed
drive we have a continuous feed rate
anywhere ranging from point 3 2 420 mill
or hour it's just I'm come with a
standard of to feed optional but you can
add up to 4 feet per bioreactor if you
like and also as you can see on the
bottom is the graph so as you and not
only have the pond have the capability
to control but you also have the
capability to to see the process trained
to detect any outlier any issue that may
happen and despite that may occur in you
media and you a culture as a girl so the
system also able to monitoring that and
trendy for you and you can actually see
for yourself live of what's going on
inside of your culture as well next what
we have here really is a an example that
we actually live in house using the
eight full system that is shown using
equal life we were using an e.coli
designed experiment with various
concentration of glucose and as you can
see on the graph that the system was
able to train and maintain in control at
the same time our old eight system all
eight system process parameter right on
the graph for us and we were able to
visually see what has occurred
throughout the run and I was able to
see all the data at the end of our
culture next we are going to move to buy
reactor design we can take a look at on
the other by reactor design and what's
involved various parts so typical a
basic buyer to component really you have
a you motor an impeller that very much
supply you mixing we can also use and
fermentation as your early phase of gas
supply as well so the mixing allowed
allow you to reach homogeneity missed to
have efficient mixing all throughout the
culture you have em next bat in the
bottom left is you have your spark
element which what supply gas to your
culture you have as well next up is the
sponge line which is the line that have
a filter attached to it which filtering
you gas supplies that cannon which can
be you air co2 in oxygen as well and you
have your heating cooling that Sabaton
used to control your temperature set
point you have you a computer that's
control all of your set point and new
processes you have set up next we're
going to basically touch on basically
looking at a firm enters what's the
difference between the fermenters are
such a bioreactor so today to the left
as you can see that is a fermentation
vessel and to the right you have is a
bioreactor which is primarily for cell
culture
so the main difference between a firm
enters in a bioreactor really one is
damn parish so for fermentation as we
previously discussed we use the Russian
impeller there is the Russian Empire
because it's the for the microbial of
bacteria they are more susceptible to
share so they are able to make to
basically deal with a much higher
agitation than cell culture and you have
second also is used speed of your
agitation in the motor power so ender
and the fermenters you have the you
motor usually have a much higher output
than your standard cell culture agitator
because you spend you mixing in your
information is much greatly then it's
higher are shorter than those in in cell
culture and also the rate of sparging of
air or gas so you have the radio
sparging or in various gases into
fermentation is much higher than you
would have in cell culture and also the
operating temperature range so the
temperature and fermentation then you
this way you have both cool and also a
heat because in fermentation as as you
as you OD increases the culture tend to
generate heat so you need a way to cool
down on the the culture to maintain you
the desired set point so which is why
they use the cool whereas in cell
culture it's very rare that you really
have to pull down your culture to
maintain set points mostly you just need
to maintain that too by using key and
you have your vessel ship which we're
going to be covered and next so in
fermentation in in Bari actor ship day a
bit different sources you can see here
on the
you have the fermenter is have a tourist
vertical ship whereas for you by react
to the head yeah a hemispherical bottom
ship and for self culture typical a ship
Julie a three to one and in diameter to
height ratio is for a fermenters usually
two to one it's more elongated and
violent next what we're looking at is
temperature controlled as you can see on
the picture to the left is the
bioreactor that have a heat heat plate
so you have the heat being distributed
from the bottom and then circulate all
the way up to the culture by picking up
the impellers picking up the code day
you're well mix and distributed up to
the top of the culture where you have in
the bottom which is a bioreactor where
which use a temperature control to a
jacketed first row using water is the
heat distributor and you have to the
right is your single use vessel will
choose an electric heating blanket to
provide temperature control next time
what we have is the agitation as we've
been discussed so you have on the top
right is your rushed and type in power
to have which predominantly use in your
fermentation culture and in the bottom
you have you pitch blade which use in
cell culture application you can have
the drive come with various rally we can
have magnetic drive as well as doing
drive
you can have dabbled mechanical seals as
well next what we're looking at is the
impeller ship which is for oxygen
transfer now the Russian type impeller
is more efficient in delivering oxygen
because because fermentation is we know
have a much higher demand for oxygen so
therefore you need an impeller that can
accommodate that that can actually
supply the oxygen to maintain your set
point so for that we use scientists and
the values the Russian type impeller to
supply oxygen but also to maintain
homogeneity to allow the vulture and you
have in the middle is your pitch blade
which is second and supplying high oti
which primarily use in cell culture and
you have to the right marine blade
impeller which use and you more like
sheer sensitive cell culture so if you
have a cell line that is acceptable to
to share you would use a marine impeller
to help next what we're looking at is an
agitation and a fermentation so you have
in fermentation is as well as discussed
we have a an agitation that an agitator
that is using the Russian type plate so
for coming for fermentation application
it the agitation typically perform at a
higher rpm to maximize oxygen transfer
rate and also provide higher to ability
unless concern for or sugar to the cells
so a so the Russian like impeller are
typically used for that and you have the
impeller blade typically possess a Patou
design is showing here to the right
despair
next what we're looking at is the cell
culture umbrella too so you have to the
left from left to right if you have your
spam filter with the impeller for
suspension cells or you micro carrier
cells and men profusion and you have
followed that is your cell live Emperor
for low share and high oxygenated in
michael carrick culture and you have
following that is the pattern for low
shear basket impeller without the basket
sunshine year but later world and you
have next is your page played impeller
for higher version with for low shear
for a million cell culture and then you
have you marine blade impeller for the
growth of insects and other cultures
next you have a buffer buffer is priya
is is used to help breaking the culture
to basic lease we supply gas more
efficiently and help to maintain a more
homogeneity within the culture while
battles are usually located along side
of the vessel to help breaking any
vortex and to help maintain homogeneity
all throughout the culture
now we next is the fermenters and value
of the differences when when it comes
down to the impeller spacing in the bath
is so with to empower we will have you
have usually eat a the l1 weights equal
to one impeller in diameter so if you
look here too though to the right and
the bottom where l1 your Emperor is
located about 11 diameter of the
impeller that you are using in that
bioreactor way if you need to with three
impeller your spacing it is 1.5 impeller
and in diameter apart from each other on
the shaft in de perfil are equally
spacing on either side of the vessel
next you have your typical bioprocess
parameter for for biological such as
temperature in pH and do and you have
your mechanical such as aeration and
forming and pressure and you have also
as we discuss is your temperature
control from which done by cooling can
be the water jacketed versa can use a
chiller to as you as you cooling device
where it circulate ethylene or vehicle
an interface product to provide freeze
for protection and rusting inhibiting
Britain the cooling device and you have
you heat with supply using your water
jacketed and also can be used
electricity and throw heating blanket
and steam you for use steam in place a
bioreactor
next this is we're really showing a
control of is an example of control or
bad the system maintained and controlled
you're a desired set point here we're
showing that for using temperature you
have your RTD embedded inside the
bioreactor which determine or get a
reading and then send it to the
controller then two then the controller
then compare that reading truly a
process set point and then determine
whether to activate the heat or the
cooling in order to maintain that set
that designs that point the scientists
of the end user has established next you
have you is your peeis you chat on
traditional ph control from our ph probe
we have a typical ph probe which used to
measure you electrochemical potential
between the non liquid inside the glass
electrode and an unknown liquid outside
you have right now you can get both on
invasive and noninvasive ph and as i
will know the ph probe limit is
fluorescent and it's detect of hydrogen
ion and convert that IJ ion
concentration to give you a ph rating
next year have you do control and as
well now you can get VD evasive meaning
that it's touching your culture with
non-invasive and that it's not touching
your culture by jabari and you can get
your photographic problem it's an
external voltage is needed to use that
with supply by the bark the controller
and as you can see in the bottom is
showing you the anode and the electrode
so our solution that's need to end that
mean in order for the pro to be able to
give you a accurate and operating
correctly
make sure we have a deal control
strategy for communications agitation
how long will increase do so for
starting and most fermentation you have
usually the goal is to ramp up the
agitation to maintain the deal now as
you OD increases and you're struggling
to maintain deal then you basically add
starts watching air to maintain to
maintain that set point where when air
basically reach its maximum output and
unable to maintain the deals that point
then you will supplement that by barging
in oxygen as well to maintain that set
point and this method is primarily used
for sale on fermentation next we have is
a deal control strategy for cell culture
so agitation often stay constant on in
cell culture and may vary slightly
depending on the processes mostly
controlled by the videos must've control
by sparging either air or oxygen to the
culture and you can either use a macro
micro sparging or a macro micro is more
efficient in oxygen delivery however may
cause some damage some shear damage to
sell and that is sheer sensitive
next what we go into total discuss is
different artists that use to deliver a
gas into the culture so you have here
you have to the left is your single RF
which is pretty much used as a single
hole that use to deliver guess the
culture or you can have the n use in the
center here arrange part two to deliver
gas and drinks produce is primarily used
for you more share sensitive cell line
and to deliver a bigger bubble to help
wait with the sharing and also you have
your centered steel sparge which I used
primarily for your mobile boss Abbas
cell line that is not as she is
sensitive as a cell for Papa primarily
on your fermentation processes next year
and what you have here really is your
typical filters that we use in the
bioreactor as the stair is the gas
filter which filter your gas to allow
the gas to enter your vessel steadily in
order to prevent contamination next what
we're looking at is different McConnell
mechanism that control the gas delivery
so you have on the top right is you
standard analog rota meter that supply
gas and you have on the bottom right is
a TM FC which is a thermal mass flow
controller which is more accurate and
measured temperature changes across
heated element which which is then
transferred into mass of air or gas it's
not sensitive to temperature or pressure
so it's electronic control automatically
by the controller system
next we have a firm control apparatus so
this agitation device because for some
application you will get from in your
culture so this agitation device help
maintain with phone so on the on the
right if you look on the right on the
top here you have here right mid to in
the I station device so you will have
some phone some NT formed in housing
there and there's the phone which until
they NT form and the phone would be
dissolve and civic dissipate and
throughout the culture next we're going
to move to mode of operation so there
are typically three mode as we discussed
earlier days bad and Fred batch and also
perfusion so we're batch is the process
where you have your initial medium is
transferred into the vessel and then you
immaculately with a culture of your
critical parameters temperature
agitation and pH in deal are monitored
during the processing and the initial
carbon source become depleted by the
culture consumption and product is
recovered in the new harvest so you
don't three days no food or no other to
use it pretty much inoculate and at the
end of the culture is the viability
decrease in your harvest so here is it's
a slide that's showing the exact that
what happens or you're heavy on the top
left of the of the graph and in red so
you have that's pretty much UV media in
your subject and on in blue in the
middle of the graph is your cell and in
yellow is your product so you have you
as your cell density increase in blue it
consumed the subject the substrate and
drive it down until it's depleted and
then you have used cell number
can scratch because there is no more
carbon source for them to console next
what we have is a fed-batch so fed-batch
is when you pretty much you you
inoculate you you try to you bioreactor
and your fermenter with media you will
not even actually II culture and you do
you can do in Tim an intimate and feed
where you determine the depleting at
what day that the culture is depleting
all of the carbon source and you
basically replenish that that sauce and
as as you replenishing it you do
yourself cultured and will continue and
prolong however you're gonna run out of
working volume in the barrier to us at
some point and also the voice
accumulation oswell gonna become a
factor where you as well as to publish
the culture as well so this cafe is
showing you if it's a good profile of
how's that occur so you have here on on
the on the top left you have you start
with you with a substrate and then you
would feed and you maintain that
substrate in the cell density would you
could continue an anchorage and you
would get a high yield and in
productivity due to the higher number of
cells now as is you cell density
increase in the byproduct it is the
voice increase then you know the
viability decrease then you pretty much
food garbage and the culture next is
what you have is you continuous infusion
process where you are simultaneously
doing a feed as you also removing you
supernatant or your product but I've
matter because Carmel taneously without
removing the cell where you basically
find a way to maintain the cells in the
bioreactor using various mechanism so
there's various mechanism which is going
to be discussing the bed and that
profile looks like that as you can see
so you have your subunits your substrate
and as you reach that place when you
start for fusion you basically start
also sort of supply and also housed at
the same time so you have a constant
rate of product being produced as you
shelled entity then continuously
Anchorage and this type of culture tend
to last a lot longer than your batch in
your feedback because you're able to
maintain a constant feed and also as you
feeling you are also moving the ways in
the product as well which is which allow
the cell to have a better environment
for growth next what we can look at is
some technology which use for suspension
cell culture so here in this graph
really we are basically comparing the
different mode of operation and looking
at the number of cells you can
accomplish so here on the top as you can
see we have cell density growth mode and
sell retention device and also we have
been you put activity see as you can see
and batch processes we were able to can
basically achieve anywhere from one to
five million cells from mill where you
have relative local activity and as
compared to fed-batch away were able to
get from 22 25 million cells from mill
and with a with a bit more productivity
is compared to a badge and you have for
confusion you did various technology
that you can use such as hollow fiber
ATF and spin filter along with civets
centuries available in the industry so
you can achieve anywhere from five to
two hundred million cells for mail using
these various technology and as you can
see of course or the technology such as
the eighth year for you can
this high cell density you would
activity also of course increase all the
times so we take a look at this they are
the functionality of the ATF system
relation of it's a technology that's
operating by alternating tangible flow
creating by the action of the diaphragms
and the bottom here as you can see
that's moving upward and then downward
in order to function smoothing the
culture from and the bioreactor and and
out and at the same time you have you
have a pump that's attached to the
membrane that's heaven where the cells
cannot penetrate that membrane barrier
in which were you collecting the product
on top of oil and harvesting out next
you have is the next cell retention
device and this cell attention devices
are internal the bioreactor and that is
your spam filter this is then filtered
from in various pore size range anywhere
from 12 to 14 micron so you have
yourself cannot penetrate the membrane
of the spam filter where you have a dip
to inside the dispense filter were you
able to collect we're able to collect
you give your conditioned media
interview molecule being being produced
using a pump at the same times you are
feeling in fresh nutrient here on the
left-hand side as you can see so as
you're feeling you are also removing at
the same rate
next what we have is the technology that
use for perfusion in for you anchor
dependent cell line so you have
technology such as micro carrier micro
carrier really you can get my carrier
file from different different vendors
are available at day they come College
encoded non-college encoded they carry
charge while to facilitate the cell
attachment they have a specific density
they also come with a diameter of beads
ranging anywhere from 125 to 250
micrometer now this is a picture of
actually what a micro carrier looks like
wood cells actually attached to it in
the barrier so Eddie you as you
adherence cell then grow in a touch to
the micro carrier think you have a micro
carry retention device person that
matter that then you as you're feeling
and you're also removing you conditioned
media as well as previously show so next
is really is comparing the micro carrier
densities that you get so for your
typical batch for in micro carrier you
you get about anywhere from one to three
million cells for male and for you
fed-batch you can get anywhere from six
to ten million cells from mel and you
all for your confusion using a spam
filter you can get anywhere from 15 to
50 million sales for metal which give
you the most productivity here on the
right next what you have is the pack
that technology which is a patent
technology to happened off so it's able
to accommodate both suspension in anchor
dependent cells it's a stable so you
first then you inoculate to allow
yourselves to grow
and you have some some company that use
used to also do in the vaccines and you
see whether the day to viral infections
also as you as your cell density
increase then you basically start
pollution what's great about this this
technology is you don't have to worry
about a cell retention device you pretty
much as you feeding are you also moving
at the same rate and it's sort of this
next slide here is illustrating of what
exactly are their priorities actually
function as you can see on the left you
have you fresh medium been pumping into
the culture at the same time you have
another pump here on the right it's been
collecting you conditioned media and you
all do a product for that matter well
you don't need any attention device
because your cells already going and
embedded back there next what this slide
is showing really is in comparison to
full bottle using that packed bed system
on how much you can actually have space
and water bottle you can save so for
example for a total volume of 150 litre
in a packed bed using a pad tag bed of
over 60 litre you that's is the
equivalence of using 8471 water bottle
so for the same processor use in the
water bottle you would only need to use
it like a 682 bioreactor
next what we have really is is this
slide is showing really how you can
develop you processes using the small
scale very active we discussed earlier
and as you basically develop your
process and you establishing you your
processes then you can transfer that
process into a process development
pinched a bioreactor and that made by
showing here this small peril of
starting bioreactor and we have in-house
and as you optimize your processes using
the parallel by reactor then you can
then transfer that into you process
development 10 liters or 60 wheeler
vessel for that matter and you didn't
scale that up to your production
bioreactor and pretty much can we use
that platform as you scale up also
scaled down method as well so in summary
really choosing an operations mode that
is appropriate for the target organism
such as bacteria and suspension cells
and adherent cells there is a wide range
variety of by a governmental system to
choose from so it's important to select
one that appropriate for the type of
your process I think everybody in the
audience for participating for the time
i will take now any question that they
may have
thank you for that informative
presentation before we get started on
the question and answer session I would
like to remind our audience how to
submit questions you can submit
questions by typing them in the Q&A box
which can be found by clicking on the
green Q&A button at the lower left of
the presentation window will try to
answer as many questions as we can your
first question is stirring for the bio
brew needs to be charged right is there
battery no this not disturb for the bio
blue does not need to recharge it is a
magnetic stirrer that actually control
you be addicted a controller there is no
battery Media Days no charge associated
again Caitlin's like to give people a
moment to submit some questions
okay another moment okay if there are no
more questions I would once again like
to thank our speaker for his
presentation do you have any final
comments Mitchell a now I just would
like to know like just like to thank
everybody for their time and then focus
event in today's webinar and if there's
any more questions feel free to follow
up with us yet eppendorf and we can help
answer any of your bioreactor any review
processes question please feel free to
contact us and we'll be able to provide
you with an answer in any support in
solution you may need thank you very
much Judy forbidden area today and our
for putting this together and for all
those who participate and thank you very
much for your time
thank you I would also like to thank our
sponsor eppendorf for making today's
educational webcast possible today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through six months from the live
date you'll receive an email from lab
roots alerting you when this webcast
will be available for replay we invite
you to afford that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event see you next time goodbye